[Música]
quando era criança eu me perguntava como
é que a gente conseguiu ouvir música que
vinha de um disco e eu lembro de ter uns
três anos de idade e que querem olhar
dentro do alto falante como símbolo está
vindo e som
como eu posso ouvir as músicas do sítio
do pica-pau e da vila sésamo saindo de
dessas paisagens que eu mal consigo
enxergar
quando eu comecei a olhar mais para o
céu
meu pai me falou que aquelas estrelas
que se moviam eram satélites
quero comum antenas que a gente tinha
colocado lá no céu de longe pareciam
estrelas mas eram coisas que nós
tínhamos colocado lá funcionavam como
antenas isso também estou na cabeça como
assim sem manter lá em cima e eu sempre
fui louco por música eo via importante
na minha voz sempre de um radinho com
ela até que um dia ela me deu um rádio
dela que tinha quebrado
eu tinha 9 anos eudes monteiro e rádio
que queria ver o que tinha dentro né
e eu consertei ali eu virei cientista
curiosidade minha coragem de consertar
um negócio me mostrar um outro universo
hoje eu me preocupo com outras coisas
como por exemplo com o que tem dentro da
nossa cabeça eu quero poder enxergar lá
dentro dos nossos neurônios e eu também
me preocupo com as baterias nossos
celulares que é que acha que a bateria
do celular está bem como se a gente
pudesse enxergar lá dentro e observá-lo
operando e entender como essas coisas
funcionam e as cargas lá dentro da
bateria do celular
a gente já pode fazer isso nós elevador
de partículas
mas para isso a gente tem que lembrar de
perguntas feitas por cientistas e
pessoas ao longo de muitos séculos por
exemplo a idéia da electricidade surgiu
quando um pastor
acho um pedaço de âmbar em grego
eléctron ele raspou que ele viu que vai
atrair outros materiais
mas quem ficou mais famoso por descobrir
a eletricidade foi benjamin franklin que
ele se perguntava se o raio relâmpago
tinha a mesma natureza da electricidade
corria dentro de baterias se aquilo
podia ser canalizado
séculos depois são benjamin franklin
está falando de 1750 1830 o edno becker
el que era de uma família de cientistas
na frança vai deverá cientista e o filho
dele é um ganhou o prêmio nobel junto
com mariko eo marido dela quer o henri
becquerel federal faz experimentos com
metais aquecidos submetidos a correntes
elétricas
ele observou que uma fuga de corrente
ali naquele metal aquecido mas ele só
observou
essa ideia que foi migrando a ideia
idéias são migrantes elas pousam nas
cabeças preparadas pra usar elas de
alguma forma chegará na cabeça do edson
e muitos anos depois também do material
que ele tinha um problema para resolver
as lâmpadas que ele produzia foram
inventados por pessoas que trabalhavam
com ele no entanto ao longo dos anos
tenho queimava muito rápido de uma certa
fuga e uma corrente que ele observava e
os filamentos estragavam pesquisando
coisas e estudando e se esse problema
mas a fã dele descobriu estava
acontecendo e se colocar só mais um
elemento em um cátodo ali naquela
lâmpada ele inibe essa fuga mas ele
patente o efeito porque ele sacou que
não podia ser útil para alguma coisa
realmente é um efeito que é o utilizado
até para a produção de energia hoje e é
o efeito está no coração do acelerador
de elétrons do tipo que a gente tem aqui
do lado a 16km saque do teatro
essa foto do google maps está um
pouquinho atrasada ela na verdade 2014
quando a gente começou a terraplenagem
dos sírios o os cílios é um novo
acelerador de partículas brasileiro está
sendo construído no cnpe o centro
nacional de pesquisa em energia e
materiais
esse campus todo o campo do cnpe é um
centro de laboratórios nacionais onde
fica o o laboratório nacional de luz
síncrotron onde fica o anel o vx que foi
o primeiro acelerador de partículas
construído no hemisfério sul e onde a
gente tem também o laboratório nacional
de biociências laboratório nacional de
nanotecnologia eo laboratório nacional
de ciência tecnologia do bioetanol são
laboratórios abertos para todos os
pesquisadores o crb foi construído ao
longo dos últimos 30 anos por pessoas de
todo o brasil e de vários outros
do mundo também que convergiram aqui em
campinas e um grupo grande que tá agora
construindo sírios
o que a gente faz no acelerador de
partículas aqueles elétrons que a gente
que o edson viu então fugindo do
filamento ele patenteou como o efeito ou
é outra emissão termiônica que aquece o
negócio ele cospe homs fica no nosso
canhão de elétrons planejado pela liu
uma das nossas cientistas que fica no
meio do acelerador o que a gente faz é
com os bichos elétrons e fazeres andarem
muito rápido rápido rápido na órbita
circular aqui ou num tubo com vácuo
nessa condição imagina que eu botando
esses elétrons para correr e eles são
como corredores estão correndo muito
rápido e transpirando chega uma hora que
olha que eles fazem a curva voa suor
deles detalhes vai tomar banho de suor
o que a gente faz no acelerador como o
síncrotron ecoleta essa energia que vaza
dos elétrons quando a gente bota ele pra
correr e canalizar elas no que a gente
chama de linhas de luz que tem algumas
ainda que no algumas mais longas nos se
eles vão sair para fora
o que a gente faz vai canalizar essa luz
o suor dos elétrons é o que a gente
chama de luz síncrotron é uma radiação
muito brilhante e tem várias cores
o vx sanduíches que ele vai do
ultravioleta os raios x a gente cobre
uma gama grande de cores de luz ea em
cada estação experimental
a gente pode selecionar uma faixa destas
luzes usando prismas e espelhos e aí o
focaliza essa luz num ponto bem
pequenininho
milhares de vezes menor do que a
espessura do nosso fio de cabelo
nessa condição a gente pode fazer
tomografia num nível muito mais com
muito mais precisão do que tomografia
que a gente tem um hospital mas é o
mesmo raio x que ele é muito mais
brilhante e muito mais focado
o que a gente pode produzir no
acelerador de partículas
essa imagem que você tem um livrinho com
um desenho feito por um dos nossos
pesquisadores o meu colega eduardo e
kelis que além de matemático é um
cientista a é um desenhista amador e ele
fez essa ilustração mostrando um
pouquinho como é o anel ea idéia é
mostrar que a gente tem
algumas pessoas que são está temos 20
cientistas como eu que trabalho lá dando
suporte para a infraestrutura ea gente
atende e treina usuários que vêm de
vários lugares maioria da academia mas
muitos na indústria também eles vêm pra
ser treinados para usar esse equipamento
que serve pra que é um grande
microscópio a gente consegue ter
informação da matéria no nível atômico
pra que serve isso as pessoas que vêm
usar o o o vestígio que vão usar os
sírios fazem experimentos dos mais
variados expõe no nosso site têm uma
série de vídeos chama luz pra quê onde
essas pessoas explica um pouco do pará
que eles usam o senador
em experimentos com fósseis muitas
coisas em paleontologia você consegue
imaginar a fotografia de uma rocha que é
um ovinho de dinossauro e reconstruir
aqueles que tinham a gente faz pesquisas
com a criação de novos remédios para
isso que a gente olha dentro das células
pra achar novas maneiras de interagir
com a sua com as moléculas estão lá
dentro
cosméticos você pode determinar a
composição atômica ea composição química
por exemplo de micrometeoritos ou de
lama de rio ea gente também pode estudar
temas complexos como raízes de plantas
solo e nos cílios a gente vai dar um
salto maior ainda a gente vai ter um
feixe muito mais brilhante muito mais
focado que vai penetrar mais ainda
materiais
eu vou ter mais informação sobre fósseis
materiais para novos aviões e carros
materiais mais leves e mais resistentes
e por exemplo até estudar a e determinar
fofura ideal do sorvete
isso já se faz lá fora você pode
imaginar de tomografia do sorvete rápido
o suficiente antes de se derreter e
determinar qual é o tamanho ideal do
grão zinho de gelo e da bolinha de arte
que dá aquela gostosura o sorvete que a
gente mais gosta feixe de luz né ai lei
do raio-x parece coisa de ficção
científica
na verdade inspira um pouco de ficção
científica mas são ferramentas reais e
cientistas muitos brasileiros inclusive
não espere norte tem um monte de
aceleradores eo vestido foi o primeiro
do hemisfério sul
os sírios vai ser o mais brilhante dessa
classe à luz a justiça falou o suor dos
elétrons ali vai ser o mais brilhante e
mais focado do mundo
isso é uma construção de muitas pessoas
então cientistas se fazem com
curiosidade mas também como trabalho em
equipe e o cnpe é um produto de várias
pessoas e eu queria fazer uma pausa
agora falar de sobre trabalho em equipe
a gente voltar mais ainda no tempo e
lembrar do mito jasão e os argonautas
razão era um herói grego que tinha uma
missão ele tinha que recuperar
falando um carneiro de ouro e para isso
ele tinha que atravessar o mar negro
cheio de perigos e não sabia o que iria
encontrar o que queria enfrentar é que
ele fez ele juntou 50 heróis de outras
histórias
cada um com sua capacidade com
habilidades diferentes inclusive o argus
que construiu um navio e aí eles não
sabiam que eles vão enfrentar mas eles
estavam preparados para enfrentar muitos
problemas existe um propósito ele
estavam preparados pra botar idéias para
funcionar para resolver os problemas que
eles vão encontrar é isso um pouco o que
acontece numa instalação grande de
pesquisa como acelerador no trabalho de
uma pessoa em algumas pessoas muito
importantes em várias partes do negócio
mas se você não tiver um trabalho de
equipe e se fosse um dia um time muito
bom isso não vai acontecer
o cnpe como eu falei pra vocês é foi
feito e construído e é utilizado por
pessoas de todo mundo e eu só vou focar
em alguns desses argonautas cientistas
que estão ali porque cientistas têm essa
característica de curiosos se serem
corajosos para se lançar em aventuras
para buscar as respostas para os seus
problemas e enfrentar o desconhecido se
preparar para o desconhecido eu por
exemplo mas sim em amparo a 60
quilômetros daqui fui estudar física em
são carlos
fez graduação e mestrado lá e aí uma
oportunidade de fazer doutorado nos
estados unidos
isso significava deixar tudo que eu
conhecia fui para a costa leste terminou
o doutorado lá fui costa oeste fez mais
uma uma parte da verdade termina do
tratado na costa oeste e pensão pós doc
e aí eu fui chamada mais um chamado pra
vir pra cá sempre cnpe em 2006 e de 2016
eu faço parte do time está construindo a
partir dos sírios outra pessoa
importante nos cílios muito importante
na verdade é a liu que nasceu na china
vim para o brasil ainda criança para o
rio grande do sul foi estudar física em
curitiba
e lá se juntou ao time do professor
ricardo e outros que foram responsáveis
pela criação do primeiro acelerador e
pelo acelerador para pelo coração dos
filhos que é o cérebro do que está
construindo agora o hélio é outra pessoa
que fazer parte desse time era o menino
do interior do paraná que trabalhava
durante o dia fazer colégio técnico de
construção civil à noite mas incentivado
pelos professores foi fazer física ele
estudava à noite na madrugada com
apostilas do cursinho que ele ganhou dos
amigos e entrou em física na em curitiba
ea história que vieram para são carlos
para campinas foram para são carlos
depois vieram para campinas construiu o
vx ele mas não tenho na frança e depois
voltou pra cá pra construir uma das
linhas dos cílios
ele está focado em fazem nessa linha que
pode vai deixar a gente fazer tomografia
de uma célula de cada vez e em
tomografia e especiação química de
coisas como a bateria do seu celular
outro outra pessoa é o narciso que era
do interior da paraíba
a cidadezinha chamada malta foi estudar
física campina grande conhecer um dos
nossos a jornalistas no rio em joão
pessoa
veio para o laboratório como aluno do
nosso programa de estágio
fez doutorado em física na unicamp foi
pra frança estados unidos e aí foi
chamado para trabalhar no siris mas está
construindo uma linha de luz onde a
gente vai poder estudar materiais em
condições extremas de temperatura e
pressão
temperaturas como o centro do sol e
pressão como a do centro de júpiter
nessas condições depois da criação de
materiais como diamantes e propor novos
materiais
por último a verônica que era uma menina
que como como eu olhava para o céu só
tava lá no interior de sergipe
ela se perguntava como a gente podia
trazer aquela luz das estrelas
ali pra terra naquele meio do sertão
hoje depois de ter vindo como usuária e
do canadá estudar ela voltou com uma
pesquisadora e ela pesquisa materiais
luminescentes elas são e com estradas
pavimentadas com o material que é
iluminado sem eletricidade
todas essas pessoas e muitas outras
inclusive alguns que estão aqui hoje de
várias especialidades físico
como isso que eu falei mas engenheiros
químicos biólogos e jornalistas
dentistas todos estão convergindo no
cnpe muitos deles além dos sírios que é
esse projeto que tem nome de estrela e
jeito de nave espacial onde a gente está
fazendo coisas que são realmente um
presente para o futuro da ciência no
brasil
vamos começar com algumas estações
experimentais os filhos vai poder ter
até 40 estações funcionando ao mesmo
tempo eu estou construindo uma delas que
é essa o número quatro que e outras
linhas vão surgir para resolver
problemas que a gente nem imagina ainda
eu tenho problemas com a bateria do
celular e com os meus neurônios mas
daqui a cinco dez anos os pesquisadores
vão poder tá fazendo perguntas que a
gente não imagina ainda nosso conselho
pra vocês estão respeitando responder
essa pergunta de como se fazem os
cientistas é que eu acho que sente se
fazem com curiosidade
são crianças que nunca parar de
perguntar por que fazem coragem você tem
que ter coragem para enfrentar o
desconhecido para se preparar porque
você não imagina você vai encontrar você
tem que ter carinho porque assim é uma
construção coletiva e você tem que
conseguir trabalho em equipe
você tem que pensar no próximo eles têm
que pensar no futuro quem sabe no futuro
as pessoas que estão aqui assistindo
isso quando está inspirado para
continuar a entrar com a gente nessa
jornada e resolver os problemas que nos
perturbam hoje com uma bateria do
celular que já deve está acabando para
muita gente e como a gente pode fazer
nosso cérebro funcionar em cada vez
melhor porque a gente quer trabalhar com
as inteligências artificiais e não ser
escravo da elza país precisa conservar a
nossa também
então isso tudo tá à disposição da gente
no brasil é um motivo de orgulho espero
que você se anime com isso e busquem
saber mais sobre o que acontece lá
o projeto todo brasileiro nossa empresa
já estão se especializando já tem
participação de mais 150 empresas na
construção do acelerador dos sírios que
vai ser inaugurada este ano e é isso
curiosidade em coragem e carinho é assim
que a gente vai sentir
obrigada
[Aplausos]